تجتاح درجات الحرارة الحارقة الصين
وتحول الاختبارات الجماعية المرغوبة إلى
مهمة خطيرة
تظهر وسائل الإعلام الحكومية أن العمال
المطلوبين ينهارون أثناء العمل بسبب ما
تقول مقاطع الفيديو إنها ضربة شمس
في شرق الصين ، تتقيأ عاملة مرغوبة
على الأرض بينما يهرع
زملائها لتمزيق بدلة المواد الخطرة.
غير قادرة على الوقوف ، لقد حملت بعيدًا ،
إنه مشهد يلعب في جميع أنحاء الصين
يغمى عليه وهو يسقط على الأرض
مستلقيًا بلا حراك
يكافح من أجل تنفس
العمال المرغوبين لساعات طويلة في
الحرارة الخانقة التي تفاقمت من
رأسهم إلى أخمص القدمين ، معدات واقية للجسم
بالكامل ليست ماء وفقًا لـ
وسائل الإعلام الحكومية يتدفق العرق من المواد
الخطرة لهذا العامل الذي يتناسب مع حمامات العرق الموجودة
داخل المعدات الواقية التي تبطن
داخل
قفازاتهم المطاطية ، حيث تتطلب درجات الحرارة المرتفعة التي تتزامن مع
ارتفاع حالات الطمع في
المدن في جميع أنحاء الصين بما في ذلك هنا في
بكين اختبار copa مؤخرًا من
أجل الدخول إلى أي  مكان عام يعني أن على
كل شاب وكبير
ومرضى الانتظار طويلاً  مثل هذه الأشياء
في الحرارة القاسية ،
يكون الأمر صعبًا
حقًا وأنت تعلم أنه مرهق وتشعر بأنك
تشعر في كثير من الأحيان أنك تشعر بالقلق لأن
لديك أشياء يجب القيام
بها للبقاء على قيد الحياة ، فإن العمال الطامعين يبدعون في
احتضان كتل الجليد العملاقة
ووضعها على ظهورهم.  يقوم
الزملاء بالقدم والقدم بفرك الثلج على بعضهم البعض
ويلصقون زجاجات الماء المثلج
لأنفسهم ،
وقد قالت بعض السلطات الآن إن
العمال المطلوبين يمكنهم ارتداء البولي بروبلين الذي لا يغطي
أجسادهم بالكامل ،
وقد شهدت عشرات المدن
درجات حرارة عالية قياسية الأسبوع الماضي
أصدرت أكثر من 80 مدينة  تنبيهات حمراء مع
بعض درجات حرارة قطع الأشجار التي تزيد عن
110 درجة فهرنهايت في وسط
الصين ، أغلق متحف بعد ذوبان السقف
في نانجينغ ، وفتحت المدينة
ملاجئ غارات جوية تحت الأرض للناس للهروب
من الحرارة ،
بينما تذبل المحاصيل وتموت
تحت درجات الحرارة المرتفعة التي جفت بها التربة.
وتصدع الأضرار التي لحقت بإنتاج المحاصيل في الصين
يهدد بدفع التضخم إلى الارتفاع مما
يزيد من الضغط  حول الاقتصاد الذي
دمره الوباء بالفعل ، ولكن في
خليج صغير في الصين ، حتى عمال الرعاية الصحية الذين تم
نقلهم إلى المستشفى بسبب الإنهاك الحراري ، حصلوا على تأثير
إيجابي من السلطات ،
يُظهر مقطع الفيديو الدعائي هذا
مسؤولين حكوميين يزورون العمال المطلوبين في
وحدة العناية المركزة بينما
يظهرون المرضى الساكنين في السرير.
يحشد الناس للعمل معًا من أجل
النصر ضدك